thank you
[Music]
all right we're going to talk about
names right now because uh a mom in
North Carolina she had a baby
after some time she kind of regretted
the name she gave the baby well you
could change it immediately yeah so she
went and changed it was it bork
was it abort I wish oh plus fives
wow you're fast so um no it actually was
something kind of normal sounding but
people started telling her hey I think
people are gonna make fun of your kid
when he reaches a certain age yeah why
are people so afraid of that I don't
know I don't know it's like you will not
Escape that won't you wanna have your
kid like have a little weird name so
they do get [ __ ] with because that
builds character I think that I don't
know if that's the reason that they
should here's the thing like all of the
people that I know that are crushing it
in life they have some story of trauma
or whatever right yeah and I've
witnessed so many [ __ ] people that
had great parents that solved all their
problems they're just losers a lot of
them are just [ __ ] up hardcore
because they never faced adversity so
then now I'm thinking is having great
parenting in the way we're like it's
actually not good parenting but like the
parents did so much to remove any type
of struggle from the kid's life is that
actually a good thing no
so let's give them struggle so what's
the name let's give let's construct some
trauma let's let's make fun of this
what's the name
that's not bad that's not even a good
that's good that's like wait wait guys
don't be too quick to judge are there
two s's or One S
and is there a 15 afterwards
nah it's just regular Aspen Colorado
what was the last name though I mean the
last Colorado there's a provided last
name
oh that's the one that they thought he
would get made fun of for what I know
that's okay to be fair he will be made
fun of that let's like not [ __ ]
everybody finds a way to make it because
nobody likes pans everybody likes
pencils can what the [ __ ] do you think
for like ass ass yeah that's it yes
every kid will be made fun of it hey ass
yeah every kid's gonna make fun of it
but doesn't mean that's a bad name gives
you thick skin yeah those characters but
people make fun of you no matter what it
could be your face
yeah yeah right your nose you know what
you rather have them make fun of you for
in elementary school that's not cool
Jason oh yeah you want to be safe from
being made fun of yeah Elementary School
they'll make fun of you for things that
aren't even jokes yeah like they'll
they'll be like you're wearing blue
oh we just made fun of your name yeah
we're just call them gays and Cheney
right now but it's not making fun it's
just giving uh an example what a stupid
name dude are you trying to go let's go
through everyone's names and make the
schoolyard joke of it everybody used to
say like um dick none yeah dick none I
like I like I like dick none they saw
his rhyming with dick or like you know
Nickelodeon that was a funny one
Nickelodeon growing up I was getting
chased around by everyone and they'd
always call me Dumbo and that would make
me cry when I was in like third grade
and that was like Nick
that has nothing to do with your name
though my name no it doesn't that's just
my face that's not that bad because my
last name was Emma Mama yeah Joe mama oh
okay but that's cool that became like
your signature though I thought it was
cool I don't know scary yeah no but I
mean in elementary school in elementary
school they can't they call me all kinds
of names but I but I did the same thing
right yeah but kids are so dumb right
it's like they're [ __ ] dumb like
Joe mama in context can be cool or it's
like maybe at a certain age that's like
the best disc possible you know what I
mean it's like it's like oh that's Ryan
that's no he's crying but it's like
that's also a stupid joke you know what
I mean like people get past it he just
caught just kept calling me Chinese
it's funny yeah yeah that's [ __ ] fine
you're Chinese
like a [ __ ] comedian all right he's
like hey Chinese he's come here Chinese
Keenan Ivory wins
funny yeah no one ever called you can't
huh yeah people have called me that but
I feel like I grew up with so many
people making fun of my name that I got
desensitized to it it's like he didn't
he didn't mind can't but when somebody
said can not
yeah yeah
because it has that like delay it's the
same dude I'm so desensitized to people
making fun of my name because I've got
it some of us are weaker what was the
name that was the original name his name
originally was Aspen and they changed it
to Luke
but that's the way kids would do it it
would be such a stretch it's a stupid
thing yeah but Luca I mean that's easier
to me dude yeah changing your kid's name
that like if you want your kid to have
one name and then you change it because
you're worried that someone's gonna make
fun of it is like the dumbest reason I
think the best thing you can do
is name your kid what a [ __ ] up name
that's gonna be made fun of you mean
like Meet the Parents where they're like
named Gaylord focker yeah that's pretty
funny you wanna you wanna hear a real
some real [ __ ] up names real names yes
so uh my friend who's a nurse at a
hospital she uh had a mom name her kid
meconius do you know what mcconius is
meconius is what I believe that's what
you call uh or maybe it's meconium it's
what you call the first [ __ ] a baby
takes that's all liquidy why
because she heard them say it in the
hospital and she thought it sounded well
I like that
that's a good one though but codium does
sound nice a stupid thing to do and I
applaud it there was a it's meconium
yeah meconium there was a Korean dude
that was at our school no [ __ ] his
name was Eric and his last name was shin
and we [ __ ] died laughing Eric chin
just because it's Shin Eric Eric Shin
got it like dude
erection
that's kind of that's pretty good that's
kind of funny what an idiot what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's so innocent it's like
oh [ __ ] that's funny that's funny though
like how can you not laughing
would that be [ __ ] up if you had Ed or
something at [ __ ] 14 nah just the
rest of his life you know what I mean
wouldn't that be ironic you know okay
dick none yeah dude I got no dick so
it's dick
there was also a girl in Cerritos uh I
wish I knew what happened to her her
name was header
oh she was Filipino and her parents
mispronounced Heather oh Heather and
they when they wanted to name her
Heather they accidentally wrote it as
header because that's how Filipinos
sound Heather and that's really really
uh
unfortunate because in this era it was
there was a big divide between like
Filipino Americans and like fobs so
people were always making fun of her and
she was like a pretty girl yeah that
sucks her name was actually and she
would be like hi I'm Heather it's like
don't [ __ ] lie your head or you know
like it's so [ __ ] I feel like a lot of
the times it doesn't matter what the
thing is is the how they say it to you
it's like the China thing or the header
thing yeah it doesn't even sound that
bad but like your header is like oh his
head or bad yeah honestly I thought I
thought one of the most beautiful names
for a girl was Lana until somebody's
like did you know that that's anal
backwards
yeah that's true I'm like [ __ ] I gotta
do a little bit of work for that I
remember in eighth grade the they gave a
nickname to this guy I think his name
was Fook f-h-u-c right that's tough but
here is that how you say it p-h-u-c but
he was but he was fat so then they call
him fat [ __ ] oh no that was his nickname
they'll be like hey fat [ __ ] so that
that sucks because you're getting made
up photo for two separate things but
that was his name to like high school
like everyone just called him fat [ __ ]
but I also remember it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be uh a bad thing to give
props to creative funny names you know
yeah whoever was like the [ __ ] was
like Hey dude fat [ __ ] but it really
made sense and he owned it too he was
like yo I'm fat [ __ ] yeah that's his
identity now there was this kid in in
Community College the first year I was
there his name was note n-o-t-e and he
was Chinese and I remember like I became
friends he's a cool kid and he was
saying that like oh my God like the last
school I was at people kept calling me
Hunchback of Notre Dame what it's like
dude that's pretty [ __ ] up and then
one day in school some kid behind him
goes hey Hunchback of Notre Dame and he
goes
no [Laughter]
and we're 18 already like we're like
older the cameras themselves and he
falls to his knees
spaceship comes by that is so sad that
moment it's so sad it's so sad through
the other side you're all good yeah
because I feel like oh man didn't we all
get like a weird nickname or get bullied
or like something for like a for like a
phase right that's that's the truth
though is some people are not built for
like they don't like you dude like some
people like I know I am like if you [ __ ]
with me like I'll dish it back and I'll
have fun but some people don't [ __ ]
do that but then you learn how to do
that though did you learn how to be able
to take a joke and then be able to Dish
about but then I was lucky because I
grew up with other kids and other family
and big families are are a really easy
thing to have like if you have a big
family you get thick skinned pretty
that's true and not everybody has that
so it's like [ __ ] that sucks that if you
don't have that you're alone and then
you go to a place like a new school you
don't know anybody you have anxiety
about fitting in everyone makes fun of
you you're not ready to [ __ ] zingers
back to them you know what I mean you're
just gonna be obsessed it's not joke if
you don't get it exactly I think that's
the difference because when I started
seeing that [ __ ] and I'm like oh they're
not fighting back yeah then I'm like I
don't I don't I don't know it felt it
felt weird but then if they're like
hurt but then they dish it back and it
becomes a game I think that's that's
different yeah I don't know how that's
why sometimes I don't know how to do it
I was that kid that doesn't really have
the big family dude they should have
they should have classes for that I'm
gonna do that right so now I try to
learn it like the nose thing you know
[Laughter]
I feel like I'm in like middle school
again dude I remember growing up I used
to get picked on so much all the time I
got picked on every grade for my ears
being Chinese
okay beat a little [ __ ] dude like
crying about it all the time like I used
to get picked on relentlessly not your
ears though oh dude 100 okay check this
out but Chinese is okay but the ice get
python for being Asian all the time
because wherever a lot of times wherever
I went I was like one of the only Asian
kids growing up right oh yeah Pasadena
in my first uh like my first like week
in high school I was like walking around
and look I had obviously my ears are
[ __ ] up now but they were just really
big when I was come on dude come on man
they were really gorgeous back there
okay I'm fascinating I'll tell you that
I remember I was walking around campus
and I'm on like a freshman high school
and these dudes came up and like I
didn't know them and they were like yo
what the [ __ ] they're like God damn look
at this Fool's ears y'all holy [ __ ]
these are [ __ ] huge boy What
ethnicity
oh no my God damn and then I was like
yeah
I thought they were my [ __ ] friends
for a sec and then they were like ah and
they just left and I was like whoa
bro I don't even think I have an ear
thing but I'm traumatized right now but
but eventually but eventually you
realize like look bro there's nothing
you could do about it so you might as
well [ __ ] either crack yeah you can
either you start cracking jokes back or
you just realize like hey don't take
yourself too seriously because
everyone's gonna [ __ ] dunk on you
anyway what do you do they go God damn
what would you do like after like fifth
time they're like damn what's the
rebuttal yeah every five times what
happens that's true you should have been
like hey watch out man or else I'm gonna
[ __ ] like smack you with my ear or
something nah dude
these guys
that was terrible
these guys are kind of like gangsters
bro so I was like haha and I just walked
around but then eventually like you
should have been like
yeah you're like yeah my ears are
[ __ ] bad you eventually have a good
sense of humor about it because there's
nothing else you could do about it yeah
you're everyone's gonna get these jokes
bro yeah and then afterwards he goes
straight to fight training but no but at
that time at that time I realized like
in high school I was like
crack jokes with people or you learn how
to do that then you can kind of like
it's all good everyone's just like oh
Nick Nick's like the fun guy or
something like the funny guy it's all
it's on no big deal and then you [ __ ]
them all up I never [ __ ] anybody up
there I'm like yeah dude people are
going hey hey go make fun of his ears he
loves that
man he's a fun guy because when you
start laughing about it and then you
have a good sense of hearing about it
they realize like oh that's like not a
big deal anymore like it doesn't get the
same reaction anymore I mean getting
cauliflower ear was a good choice but
that wasn't until I was like [ __ ]
until I was out of high school you know
and that just I didn't want cauliflower
just happened to me and then my coach
was like he's like hey you know what
your nickname should be you my coach
goes even what your nickname should be
it should be the ear yo like ah and I
was like yeah that's true because my
ears are [ __ ] up so when you were
fighting you were you weren't trying to
block hits with your ear to try to
cauliflower it wasn't I was trying to
block kids I was just taking hits to my
cars
foreign